the hotel chester is located in
starkville mississippi home to the
mississippi state university husband and
wife david and suki mullendore bought
the hotel in 2000. before buying the
chester david travelled the world as a
hotel troubleshooter i worked in the
hotel industry 39 years thank you for
calling hotel chester i wanted to try
and settle down and give our kids one
stable place to be
one of us got to get taller
to begin with a 36 bedroom hotel was a
real success packed with students and
locals how are you doing
then a sudden tragedy hit the family
dave was coming home
and was uh involved in a a major auto
accident we thought we lost him
that changed all of us it's overnight
he crushed his feet and was bedridden
for almost six months
[Music]
it's a little dated deport is very dated
in david's absence standards dropped and
customers stopped coming while we were
losing so much money that i had to file
for bankruptcy
the financial losses have been so bad
the bank foreclosed on their home so now
they're living in the hotel living in
the hotel working together in the hotel
i feel tired and i feel
out of sync with the world
they couldn't afford payroll so tsuki
left a job in real estate and took over
a chef and temporary manager it was my
idea that we opened a sushi restaurant
never worked in any restaurant kitchens
before in my entire life
but i knew how to make the sushi
my mom's confused but despite her best
intentions with no formal training oh
she's struggling
oh where's my knife suki spends all her
time in the hotel so she's blind to the
tens of thousands of students and
tourists who could be potential
customers
and the hotel's bedrooms and dining room
are empty most nights i just need those
entrees yeah but i guess they're coming
you know i see it in my parents eyes i
see
that they're physically exhausted that
they're mentally drained
my mom she used to be lively vibrant
she's honestly
half the woman she used to be man i
forget i'm losing my mind when i came to
this place i was 180 pounds at twisted
blue steel sex appeal and mucho hell
then this old [ __ ] has worn me down to
200 pounds of flab gab
and total no mass
[Music]
with almost no money coming into the
hotel david and tsuki are hanging on by
a very thin thread
i need gordon to help my parents because
if this hotel doesn't change it's
we lose everything this is it
[Music]
i'm in starkville mississippi's college
town i'm on my way to the hotel chester
mississippi state university founded in
1878.
any hotel with a college on their
doorstep should be absolutely thriving
not just for the students but with their
parents as well i can't wait to check
into the hotel chester
where is this place
i can't even see the sign
okay i'm gonna pull it over here got to
know where it is
how are you hey how are you
i'm looking for the hotel chester i've
never been there before you've never
been there it's fine no i'm fine i've
gone around three times
it's easy to miss easy to miss yeah yeah
i can't see any signs well there may be
one time but i mean it's not right it's
not too big okay great
excellent
thank you enjoy
[Music]
the students never go to the chester
despite the fact it's right next to the
campus
weird
there we are there
historic hotel chester entrance well
such a huge building and such a tiny
sign it's madness finally
morningstar hey how are you morning how
are you good to see you gordon good to
see you and i'm david
i see well
i finally found the place that is so
confusing there you know that there's no
sign on main street i drove straight by
and see i'm on the corner of the
building a tiny sign saying it's
historic that that's what's historic
about it that's that's historically been
a bad entrance
we have you in an executive king room
and then here's two keys for you because
i'm giving you two because men don't
follow instructions as well as women or
in case you get lucky hell yes
so you're a hands-on owner are you
running the desk all by yourself my wife
is the chef she's taught herself to meet
lady
well can i finish my spiel
oh i think we've already finished so uh
breakfast is included we do have fresh
cut fruit that's nice to know fresh cut
fruit we what would be the alternative
canned
no
uh no fruit i think
i love your sense of humor it's dry and
very funny
fresh cut fruit for breakfast yes sir
nice now i just want you to know i'm not
always at the desk okay but you'll be
able to recognize me even if i'm walking
away from you because i'm the one who
looks like he's riding a chicken riding
a chicken yeah i've never ridden a
chicken you have to show well you just
have to look at my legs oh jeez
[Laughter]
i'll go get suki okay okay great
poor chicken
okay now
[Music]
i've got a guest that wants to meet you
oh what do you do with that
gordon is here to help us out and i'm
terrified but at the same time i'm so
excited okay oh hi
hello how are you
nice to see you and don't worry i've had
worse than wet hands nice to meet you i
washed my hands that's very kind thank
you for that
right nice to meet you it's good to see
you too what's it like working with your
wife i love my wife so it's nice to be
around her until she gets her
nose out of joint she has a chef's
temperament if you're not familiar with
it right they can fly off the handle
pretty easy
bushel backgrounds i'm a hotel guy i was
in vietnam and i went to see a hotel
school so you qualified as a hotelier
wow
well
so in my view yeah that's very nice good
to hear
graduated
with a major in hotel and restaurant
management and i've been in the business
almost 40 years so in a nutshell what's
wrong with the hotel that's a question
we're not sure we don't think it's a
quality issue
neither for our rooms or our food and
beverage why don't you both show me to
the room okay
i've been a general manager of a lot of
hotels i eventually became a turnaround
guy to take on problem properties so my
big surprise here is that i'm having a
hell of a time trying to turn this thing
around
we just call it an executive king
oh dear okay
this is it yes sir what is that swings
it's uh leather but it's a rough leather
and very difficult to clean
and it's so bland i mean it's like a
cheap motel chain i feel like i'm in the
witness protection program
this is depressing here so when was the
last time the roofs were touched
2003 2003 so 10 years ago it feels like
something out of the 1970s our hotel
rooms are updated you know we tried to
call it period furniture yeah i don't
know what to say always tells you that a
place is on the decline when you walk in
you've got
walls that are a mess scuffs everywhere
and big marks on the sofas that you're
expected to pay good money to sit down
in so far
i'm not digging it i'm going to unpack
and then i'd like to come down and have
a bite to eat suki so what's your
experience in the kitchen my father had
a sushi restaurant in washington dc
parents of a japanese restaurant had my
father passed away
of course did you work in the kitchen no
just washing dishes
[Laughter]
anyway listen i'm going to unpack thank
you okay
good to see you likewise
okay
thank you
so you know i feel like the guy who
walked into a bar with a big frog on his
head
went up to the bar and asked the
bartender for a drink and the bartender
said man i tell you you got a problem
don't you and the frog said yeah i sure
do can you cut this wart off my ass
oh god can that man talk
bars and restaurants in a vibrant
college town like this are always packed
at lunch time but this place is dead i'm
lindsay how are you good there you go
let me get you something to drink jeff's
an ice cold water okay please
um what would you recommend strawberry
field sushi is very popular it's a
little bit sweeter i'll try it
las vegas as an appetizer as well and
then oh sakura five individual rolls
rolled into one
[Music]
i don't know how you
execute all that japanese food on that
menu when you're not trained it doesn't
quite make sense
oh my goodness
this is not good there's not a lot of
people in starkville that like our sushi
it's a little bit different from what
other places in starkville have
[Music]
got that slow
[Music]
sookie runs her kitchen the way she
wants to it's always takes too long in
between tickets but there was really
nothing i could do about it
this food is taking way too long i've
been waiting over an hour for raw fish
oh my god i can't take this anymore
oh god
damn it
i'm at startville mississippi's hotel
chester and i've been waiting for my
lunch for a very long time
[Music]
damn it
[Music]
oh geez
i nodded off there my god does the sushi
usually take this long yes sir what is
this one las vegas oh my god cream
cheese and asparagus then it's deep
fried and comes with a jalapenos
fried salmon with cream cheese
disgusting what a strange combination
very weird it doesn't work for me that
one i mean it's just um greasy um you
can get this out of the way as quick as
possible okay thank you you're welcome
my first impressions of the food here is
that it's as bad as the rooms
sakura
and there's cream cheese in the middle
look at that thing
so it's pretty big right so how are you
supposed to get it in your mouth
i've never eaten it before let's try
come on me we're in this together
oh no you ordered this one all on your
own that's yours
you're sure that really
open mind please wait there is no way
this is going to fit my mouth ready one
two three
i can't do it
now i know how my granddad feels we're
putting your teeth in
so you took one little bite i do
damn disaster total disaster
how'd it taste by the way
i'm very good
the sakura is very chewy sookie does try
her best but she has no idea what she's
doing
what's wrong with a sakura bland ugly
chewy strange combination
chewy
yep and impossible to put in your mouth
let me tell you about my sushi i'm not a
morimoto or nobu absolutely i'm doing my
best and i respect rice what is this one
strawberry field now look at that
strawberry on
sushi
on behalf of every japanese chef in
america i'd like to apologize it's very
weird which part is so juicy
you wouldn't cover white tuna with
strawberries and then glaze it
strawberry fields rather [ __ ] eat a
beetle
it's too sweet
strawberries don't belong with tuna i am
frustrated that gordon does not like my
sushi i've tried all i can
how are you doing honey bun
he doesn't like any he doesn't like any
of it
so truthfully what is wrong with this
place
lack of business so on an average
weekend how many guests would you do on
a busy weekend maybe 12 people are they
in-house guests or hotels usually
so virtually nobody from the outside
correct jesus
anyway where are the owners can you tell
me where they are sure
thank you
they've got just 36 bedrooms yet on a
busy night just 12 guests eat here
with food that bad i'm not surprised
congratulations
on the longest lunch i've ever had in my
entire cooking career
that was
97 minutes
yeah and half of it was raw as a novice
cook why are you making sushi it's crazy
i'm trying my best
to to at least introduce mississippi
less a little bit healthier there's
nothing healthier with my lunch maybe a
health warning
surely you should be giving the locals
what they want to eat that's why they
come wow to lindsay the only customers
we get now are the ones staying in the
hotel which is practically no one
the business is on his ass
and how much debt are you in
over 900 000
900 000
right
we are in debt please don't say you
don't know
[Music]
so far starkville mississippi's hotel
chester has been a massive letdown hotel
chester entrance well such a huge
building and such a tiny sign the dated
solas rooms are awful it's like a cheap
motel chain
strawberry on sushi the sushi is the
worst i've ever had
it's hideous and david the co-owner has
just admitted to me and to his wife that
they're almost a million dollars in debt
nine hundred thousand dollars right
you ain't dead please don't say you
don't know
i'm deeply sorry
and i'm i'm sad that you're upset
i'm that upset at you david should not
have
been hiding
the financial status
from me
finding out she's been kept in the dark
has angered suki dave i i don't know
what we are doing i do the spending side
and you do the paying side
i don't share the finances with suki
this is getting ridiculous because i'm
afraid of hurting suki's feelings calm
down no i'm not gonna come down while
the owners argue guests who have heard
about my visit are arriving at the
chester for dinner i'm just gonna go to
the restaurant which is just
straight shoot right back there all
right
and tonight the ration and hotel will be
full of people for the first time in
years i feel sorry for all of them how
long have you been waiting i would say
at least 45 minutes 45 minutes my
apologies
i don't even waiting on someone um yeah
we've been here over in about an hour
yeah i'm sorry i've never seen anything
like this before it's insane how long
these guests are waiting so
what title's this suki
oh pardon me i'm sorry i just asked what
table are you doing the very first table
the very first table
it's been well over an hour and tsuki is
only working on the first table
she's really struggling and yet david's
not stepping in to lend her hand
so you know over an hour in the service
would you go in and help her
i would but
you know that's just not my territory
right unfortunately it's like the
hotel's falling apart around you
if someone needs you in the kitchen in
the bar the reception shouldn't you be
multitasking the kitchen is her
territory okay well i'm just asking it's
your hotel i know and i appreciate that
yeah
if the kitchen's not david's territory
then maybe the rooms are
it's like touched the blinds and there's
like lots of dust all over them
kind of a beat up family looks like it
came out someone's house when they died
this is definitely not the place i wanna
hang out it seems to me that david has
checked out i don't understand what's
going on here this is not good
suki is totally out of a depth having
only dealt with one of the eight tables
waiting for food
oh no
this is awful
what's wrong they said it wasn't cooked
it's cold
mom
what's wrong
cook
you okay
just like don't even want to get her in
trouble
why should burst into tears
you okay i'm fine
help me understand what's going on no i
just
the fish is under cooked in the center
what is it that i'm missing the point i
don't understand why she's in there
playing head chef
because we don't have anyone else i mean
she became chef when my dad was in a car
accident in 2008.
he was bedridden for about six months
and then mom moved in to run the hotel
the next day my mom became a chef
overnight she
came to the hotel
saw where she thought she was needed and
jumped in the kitchen
and ever since she's been trying
to make it work
and so how long has it been functioning
like this i mean i think it's been in
this state
for about uh two or three years my dad
has taken a step back
and given up a little bit okay we have
to be strong get some fresh out get your
eyes nice and bright okay
finally i get it the hotel chester has
been in a tailspin since david's car
accident i wish stookie or david had
told me well
the beer gun interesting
suki is just trying to make this work as
best she can but she is failing
miserably and david has hotel knowledge
but since the accident he has taken a
back seat this whole place feels lost
the owners the restaurant the bedrooms
even this garden feels abandoned just
like the dinner gas the customers are
getting so pissed off i'm gonna have to
do something otherwise this place is
gonna go crazy
the hotel chester in starkville
mississippi is on the brink of financial
disaster and i finally found out why my
dad was in a car accident in 2008
david's car accident sent the hotel into
a sharp decline oh no suki is drowning
in the kitchen trying to keep the
business afloat
i would say at least 45 minutes we've
been here over in about an hour while
our husband david isn't taking the reins
i can't see the diner starve so i've
dashed over to the local supermarket
the least i can do to help poor sookie
is to cook up a few sliders before the
customers walk out
those diners don't get any food trust me
tonight it's coming from me
as ridiculous in there
an hour for appetizers crazy
[Music]
i'm so sorry man
there's a little uh beef slider from the
bbq in the garden i don't want you guys
watering away everybody got some food
now
feel a bit better
the burgers have brought suki enough
time to get through the rest of dinner
service without anyone walking out
after a long three hours everyone has
finally been fed i'm sure tsuki is as
relieved as me that dinner service is
over
how are you sookie fine fine yes that
was a tough one
it was very tough yeah yes why don't you
guys get out of here you go home let's
hook up first thing tomorrow morning how
far is home away from here this is our
home now that room what do you mean this
is your home we live here
you live on site yes
you have an apartment here no right in
there they say the handicapped room
that's our that's our home now you live
in the handicapped room
yes
can you show me
since there's an accident i gave up
everything
we have no money so we had no choice but
to live in this room
you live in here yes
there's not even a [ __ ] window
no
suki i had no idea things were this bad
well
i have to do what you have to do
i'm so sorry
well you know
sometimes
have
the best times
could you get david okay please
i don't know what else to do we have two
children
i would like for them to be um
not to have to worry about their mom and
dad
okay
so you were running this hotel this was
your baby that's right david yes and
sadly you got involved in a
tragic
car accident
yes what happened
[Music]
i broke both of my ankles and my back in
two places
we nearly lost him
i mean you know i was pretty busted up
so
i've been spending most of the past five
years just recovering
why did you sell your house
we couldn't make the payment and
you foreclosed yes
that's terrible i'm sorry i didn't know
that
and you come home every night now
into this bedroom
this is awful
it is no way to live
i think you deserve something better
i promise i'm gonna help you fix this
place
okay yes sir
thank you gordon thank you
are you guessing rest
please
sometimes i'll go seven days without
stepping out of the hotel and it's uh
it's sad i can't believe david and suki
have been living like this for years
i've never wanted to help two people so
badly i just hope i'm not too late
[Music]
that was a rough night's sleep um i
couldn't stop thinking about david and
zuki downstairs where they are
almost cooped up in that tiny room with
no windows
my sleep was rough but christ imagine
going through that for three years
like they've been doing god
david and suki have sunk so far they
have lost sight of the outside world if
they lose this hotel then they lose
everything
i need to show them the potential of
this place before it's too late it's
like a sink
[Music]
come on
this is ridiculous i can't even get my
feet wet
[Music]
david and tsuki need to see how to make
the hotel chester a success i've got a
plan
you've let this business
swallow
the both of you up
yeah it's like quicksand you know you've
lost your way
not only have you lost the connection
with each other but you've lost a
connection out there
out there
the town the students
the community both come with me i've got
something to show you that can save the
life of your hotel
[Music]
in the car please
when was the last time you two went out
for lunch
i can't remember you've never been out
for lunch together no no wow
i want to show david and suki a couple
of places that are extremely successful
because they tap in to what the
community wants
thank you thank you oh wow uh london
you're always in this position it's
usually busier actually on an
average weekend uh for instance um in
the middle of the summer how many
couples do you do
hundreds some thousands probably i mean
it gets so slam packed check some things
thank you sweet
can you believe
a thousand people a day here
good honest
mississippi and food i just want ten
percent you just want a hundred people
today
i did not know that there were that many
people eating now
i've got one more place to show david
and suki to really make sure they see
there are plenty of businesses doing
well in the town how cool is this place
oh this is
really popular you know since my
accident i really haven't gotten around
to much you know this business is a
hundred meters from your front door
thank you
now
oh my god please how many couples are
you doing a day how many what's the
numbers
um about 200 a day 200 customers and our
weekends generally double that 700
guests a day 400 of the weekends and
families as well early evenings yeah a
lot of our business revolves around uh
thank you
the purpose of this outing is to show
you how these businesses are drawing
from the university how they are open to
every market and it does translate
to the rooms you have a potential gold
mine sat there you have the traffic
you've got to tap into the community
that's what you're not doing
i'm convinced that's
correct
i thought we were always welcoming
students maybe we're wrong so that's a
yes that's definitely an eye-opener now
that i've shown david and tsuki how much
potential there is in startville i need
them to commit to turning the hotel
chester around
that was nice
i enjoyed that yeah i did too to see it
that busy for lunch it was incredible
the business is
booming there david you need to get your
head back in the game that's right i got
some great ideas but you two have to be
ready for change
gordon whatever
direction you help us to get on we're
not going to waver off of that
[Music]
when i arrived at starkville
mississippi's hotel chester it was
invisible on the main street hotel
chester entrance well that's a huge
building and such a tiny sign and
failing to appeal to the people who
could make it a success the college
students i'm convinced suki and david
are now ready for change whatever
direction you help us to get on we're
not going to waver off of that
[Music]
so now it's time to reveal the new hotel
to david and suki and their team
oh my god look at that
[Music]
sure as hell don't have to worry about
it that's wonderful we have a sign
welcome to the new hotel chester
you're no longer hidden on the main
street
now customers locals identifying that it
is a hotel is it big enough for you
david
yeah i think it's really really great
there is the biggest marketing tool
you'll ever need i love it
[Music]
should we have a look inside yeah i'm
looking forward to seeing what gordon
has done with the inside of the hotel
are you ready oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
well jump in let's go ahead and get
going please this is definitely lovely
lovely lovely yes i love it john is the
drab and the dullness now this room has
character isn't
this beautiful i'm genuinely thrilled if
i could i'd do a somersault backwards
and then if gordon had let me i'd kiss
him and even if he doesn't i may drag
him in and give him a big old kiss right
on the damn lips
megan nice to see you that you're happy
very happy
it's more than i can have hoped for and
it seems to be the beginning of the end
of our struggle
do you think the parents are those 20
000 students yes
in the university will want to stay here
now yes all right let's see one more
room yes yes let's go all right oh my
god oh my god
damn i love this room beautiful
i'm in a dream wonderful beautiful
beautiful beautiful i mean i can ask
more sookie this is not a chain hotel
this is your hotel no that's right
something to be proud of oh that's
awesome i've got something else to show
you this one
you're gonna absolutely love ready
[Music]
please i'd like to welcome you all to
your stunning beer garden there we go oh
look at that
oh my god
oh
this is what i call a beer gun damn oh
yeah okay modern benches so we have
communal benches as well large parties
families additional space up there as
well we've taken advantage of stunning
furniture that's nice beautiful i love
it you go into the gazebo we have the
most amazing local beers
craft beers on tap
and these stunning craft beers that can
rotate local beers to sort of promote
stuff locally that's awesome the beer
garden is awesome i'm gonna christen it
myself and somebody's gonna have to
carry me out of it before we open the
doors to the public
there's one more thing i'd like to show
you
please come with me yes right i love
this garden out here
welcome to the new hotel chester's
stunning beer gardens
food this hotel is in a vibrant college
town in the heart of mississippi so i've
created a menu that will attract a
younger crowd and highlight southern
comfort food
gone
is the fusion confusion
i'm sorry all gone good
southern food fits the location how can
we be in startville and not have
stunning fried green tomatoes next to
that we have oyster bacon po boy fried
crispy oysters crispy bacon with a
stunning spicy remillard and gordon's
burger he's a chef and he from time to
time comes up with some stunning recipes
for burgers this burger recipe is
featured at planet hollywood in vegas
and it is to die for the new menu
complements the state of mississippi i
think it really suits the beer garden
wonderful wonderful idea suki i have
something for you that's going to make
your life in the kitchen a whole lot
easier being with you one second please
now i've got someone i'd like to
introduce you to
um someone who very special with two uh
unique assistants come through please
say hello to enrique williams now she'll
beat hotel chester's new head chef this
lady is a very experienced chef and she
absolutely knows her stuff i'm covering
enrique's salary
i'm taking care of that until this place
picks up and you can afford to keep it
yourself
you kiss him
having suki in the kitchen kind of broke
my heart every day so i'm really looking
forward to getting to know the chef and
her apprentices and giving them all the
support i possibly can tsuki i want you
to keep cooking but i want you to have a
bit of fun with it and here's how it's
going to work
suki's robotic grill skewers chicken
beef shrimp garlic
ginger soy marinade
that's a robot it's a personal touch i
love it i love the change rabata is
classic japanese barbecue when you think
of a bada grill you think marinated
japanese spa it's easy to execute and
you know what it cuts a little bit of
slack in the kitchen it gives the
kitchen a bit of time now all of you sit
down and tuck in thank you so much
thanks gordon
that looks so damn good doesn't it
with word out to the locals and the
college students about the chester's new
vibe this hotel is ready for business
how are you all doing checking in
for 200
as the new younger clientele begin
checking in it's clear the renovated
rooms are a hit
this is awesome
it feels so big and so bright just wow
we need one of these comforters at home
while the rooms are proven to impress
the renovated beer garden is also
creating a buzz with students parents
and locals we need to get a little taste
yeah everybody needs to wear something
different fried green tomatoes do you
want anything from the grill that's my
uh my little one of everything what are
you drinking everybody david seems
reinvigorated as an owner and is really
getting into it let me get your glasses
just call them out to me i'm thrilled to
death just looking out there and seeing
people eating good food and drinking
good craft beers and conversing is
exactly the kind of environment i wanted
out there i need a burger medium of fish
and chips
poor pork and without sookie in the
kitchen the new head chef is doing a
fantastic job of making wonderful meals
and getting them out in a timely manner
that is it for high one so now we're
working high too
make him sweat god damn it there you go
all right buddy the biggest thing gordon
has done is giving me a new sense of
confidence and an opportunity to have my
wife be my wife again my favorite has
been the uh gordon's hamburger and i'm
not a hamburger eater and it's a
fantastic and it's a money back
guarantee i'll give you money back if
you don't like it okay okay thank you
that's the best burger in starkville
without a close second it is the best of
everything
now that the hotel chester is catering
to what the locals want and with suki
and david embracing the changes i know
my job here is almost done
time to say goodbye
hey gordon i'm going to miss you both
we're going to meet you too look after
each other embrace these students
their parents and get this hotel full
when i see you behind that bar serving
pints that for me is you and your
element all right take care of
yourselves yes sir okay well i'm done
seeing you bouncing around out there
tonight happy in front of customers
rather than stressed good to see you
take care yourself
wow
i'm sorry i forgot one little thing can
you come with me please
one little thing before i go
the relaunch of the hotel chester is a
huge success can you come with me please
yeah now suki and david are on their way
to making this hotel the talk of the
town get in the car please but before i
leave i have one more surprise for them
right there's one more little thing i
wanted to show you
this place beautiful that gorgeous pool
there
both you
come in for two seconds
[Music]
now
living
in that tiny room with no windows is not
the way to live so
this
is your new apartment
i've rented this for the next six months
and i'm sure when the business kicks off
you'll have sufficient funds to rent
this apartment
i would love it open playing kitchen
lounge have a quick look at the bedrooms
through there beautiful this is just
what we really needed for dave
and me to get away
there we go oh dave this is nice oh this
is this is nice
thank you
some time out
that is yours
thank you so much thank you thank you
again that's awesome
um just damn flabbergasted actually
being on site and not having time out
of your hotel
you were blind to the potential on your
doorstep
was ridiculous
we thought gordon was just coming here
to help us with the business he ended up
being
helping us emotionally our marriage
he very much wanted for us to be
together and that was so lovely for them
awesome no question about it really
really nice yes
thank you again now i'm going to hug you
too
take care
okay
spend some quality time together uh you
deserve it good night and good luck all
right bye gordon
it's a new start for me
and it's just definitely a new start for
suki i'm gonna get naked in the pool
right now
it's so nice to see two people
finally happy
strawberries on [ __ ] sushi
what was she thinking
[Music]
since my visit the hotel chester's
bookings have gone up have you all
stayed with us before no this is the
first time and the guests are enjoying
the new improvements it's just not
generic run in the mail i think this is
something special now it does feel
special like it's it's actually had a
touch of care given to it
with the new menu and beer garden the
hotel has become a local hit with a
college kid i don't know what this is
but android
craft beer you have uh-huh i mean it was
outstanding was it yes i mean the local
brewery mississippi plus you had a mix
of everything oh so you had the stampers
the new buzz around town means the hotel
chester is now bringing in thousands of
guests every weekend and david and suki
are working as a team again next march
8th was a booked
for a reception for about 150 to 200
people so they went all over 36 rooms
for two nights
gordon has saved us our relationship
with husband and wife
is better wealthy we are now partners
i want to give you all a help
what gordon has done for us means
everything to us
and i think gordon's helped to put the
hotel on the map let's go suck face
you